[Musica]
[Applauso]
il test il luglio del 92 era un lunedì
esattamente 23 anni prima
una domenica il primo uomo aveva calcato
il suolo brullo della luna per la prima
volta un piccolo passo per l'uomo un
grande passo per l'umanità this aveva
superato un limite che fino a poco tempo
prima appariva impossibile
e stato proprio quel giorno che ho
iniziato e disimparare il concetto di
limite aveva infatti iniziato a
scalciare nella pancia di mia madre per
nascere il giorno fatidico sarebbe
dovuto essere da autunno inoltrato
e invece fuori faceva un caldo da
sciogliersi era era appunto il 20 luglio
la mia famiglia stava pranzando
all'aperto uno di quei pranzi pugliesi
testate nella tenuta di campagna di
famiglia e alla tv passava alla notizia
della strage di via d'amelio che si era
era accaduto il giorno precedente di un
altro fatto ingiusto che era accaduto in
bosnia una sede di un giornale era stata
rasa al suolo come è un obiettivo di
guerra
quindi il ronzio e il sottofondo di quei
minuti di quel pranzo raccontavano di
220 ingiusti ecco anche io avevo scelto
un momento ingiusto per per nascere
ero ansiosa di venire al mondo venire al
mondo mi è sempre piaciuto questo
costrutto perché partenza il movimento
che vivere comporta l'eterno tenderà
qualcosa non ho urlato a terra come il
primo uomo che vide l lei che alle zone
però ho pianto con tutto il fiato che
aveva in corpo inizia una conquista
la forma di rompiscatole che mi sarei
costruita negli anni lo avrei fatto poi
26 anni più tardi atterrando
all'aeroporto di new york ma di questo
vi parlerò fra poco da allora da quel
torrido lunedì di luglio
ce l'ho messa tutta per decostruire il
concetto di limite di confine che questa
società sembra stesso volerci insegnare
e di default
quando parlo di limiti parlò di limiti
materiali e astratti individuali e
collettivi di tutti quei limiti che
fanno da spartiacque tra le persone e le
possibilità soprattutto quello che sono
e tutto quello che invece potrebbero
essere diventare esprimere perfino avere
il diritto di pretendere dal mondo ad
esempio ero già per la verità
all'età di quattro anni senza saperlo
quando dicevo al mio ortopedico tutta
impettita con un caschetto che
fantaghirò scansati l'avete visto nella
slide precedente è uno di quei tagli che
le nostre mamme spesso ci hanno inflitto
quando siamo state bambine
ecco e dicevo al mio ortopedico tutta
impettita indispettita quasi che non era
giusto che i tutori che dovevamo portare
alle tombe non dovessero essere erosa
colorati così da poterli abbinare
vestiti o i vestiti delle delle nostre
bambole
ecco io all'epoca non potevo immaginare
che invece il gender gap sarebbe stata
un'altra alle condanne più infami ancora
da subire in questo millennio che ci
avrebbe accompagnato quindi in questi
anni non potevo di certo immaginare che
sono in italia le donne avrebbero
superato di 1,7 milioni gli uomini ma
anche gli uomini li avrebbero superate
per qualche milione il numero di
occupati e che come se non bastasse alle
donne sarebbe spettata una retribuzione
di molto minore a parità di mansione
come se non hanno pensate lavorassimo il
mese di gennaio qualche giorno di
febbraio totalmente gratis per non
pensare ai paesi in via di sviluppo se
allarghiamo lo sguardo a livello
mondiale
lì la povertà grava veramente come un
macigno sulle spalle di e ragazze e
donne che in 130 milioni non hanno mai
varcato la soglia di una scuola
io all'epoca tutto questo non lo sapevo
ancora il mondo non lo sapeva ancora o
meglio faceva finta che non fosse un
problema urgente da affrontare ed
aggredire perché se l'avessi saputo sono
sicura che avrei detto indispettita al
medico anche questo ho imparato a
superare il concetto di limite a
decostruirlo più anziano quando sono
arrivata a capire una semplice cosa che
invece di adagiarmi sul dispiacere per
qualcosa che ne occhi appariva ingiusto
bisognava agire e farlo in un momento
specifico cioè prima che la rabbia
potesse
aderire o sminuire lo slancio che serve
sempre per cambiare le realtà includendo
il 9 possibilità ripensando alle intere
realtà credo che la prima volta una
delle prime volte in cui abbia
coscientemente incluso la nuova
possibilità sia stato quando avevo 13
anni mi sono posta una domanda semplice
perché non avevo mai visto in tv un
concorrente con disabilità magari un
telequiz uno di quei quiz che mi piaceva
guardare dopo pranzo pieno di ragazzini
intraprendenti che si sfidavano fra loro
a colpi di domande
ecco è successa una cosa abbastanza
singolare un mese dopo soltanto come se
dopo dopo un po di provini mi sono
ritrovata sotto i riflettori come questi
davanti a delle telecamere come quella
con a fianco mike buongiorno che
simpaticamente mi diceva che cammina o
anche meglio di lui
lo so che lo so che in questo momento
starebbe aspettando la prova fotografica
ma non ci sarà
ecco prima di quella trasmissione
regista volle parlare a me ea mio padre
per sapere se ci fossero la necessità
particolari in merito alla trasmissione
e io va dall'alto dei miei tredici anni
dell'incoscienza che accompagna la
nostra adolescenza ma anche di quella
giusta lucidità
risposi no non ho nessuna necessità
ulteriore però vorrei non essere l'unica
dopo qualche tempo in maniera inaudita
per le regole dello spettacolo e di
quella piccola scatoletta i concorrenti
con disabilità furono non più di un paio
ecco in quel momento mi ero resa conto
di aver tolto un ulteriore mattoncino al
muro degli stereotipi di aver reso
maistre in una diversità perché questo
bisogna fare e trasmettere ogni
diversità renderà visibile farla
conoscere perché solo in questa maniera
capiremo che la differenza non è un
limite ma un enorme ricchezza
ma i limiti che ho dovuto superare nel
tempo e negli anni non sono stati solo
degli stereotipi ideali hanno avuto le
sembianze fiscale di ascensori fuori uso
gli automobili parcheggiate
indebitamente davanti a una rampa è in
questa maniera che l'ambiente intorno a
diventare in accogliente inospitale
arcigno di mente quasi anzi è proprio
questa la definizione che dalla
convenzione onu sui diritti delle
persone con disabilità la disabilità e
un'interazione negativa fra l'ambiente è
l'individuo e no non bisogna di certo
pensare che queste barriere materiali
siano proprio e solo dei luoghi meno
sviluppati di questo pianeta perché io
le ho incontrate in quasi tutti i luoghi
già avuto modo di visitare o in cui ho
abitato li ho trovati
persino nel cuore d'europa a bruxelles
intorno a quel parlamento europeo in cui
ha avuto la fortuna di lavorare per
qualche mese e c'è un episodio che mi
piace ricordare di quei mesi ed è la
sensazione che provavo quando scendevo
la rampa d'entrata posteriore del
parlamento che è creato in maniera
particolare sulla scale e rampe messe
insieme e quando ci scivolavo pensavo
che è così che dovrebbe essere il mondo
senza spigoli obbligatori
e senza che niente e nessuno possa
rilasciare delle patenti di accesso
su questo o globo ho avuto modo di
rotolare cento ho spinto queste ruote su
ogni tipo di superficie anche la più
dissestata arrivando a sentire stavo e
pompare sotto minimo centimetro di pelle
e oltre questa fatica diciamo fisica
ho sempre cercato di andare oltre di
scoprire persino qual era il confine
ultimo dell'oceano l'ho superato
vi ricordate quando vi ho detto di aver
urlato a terra
una volta arrivata in america un anno fa
mentre ero al british museum di londra
col mio fidanzato ero da mangiare la
stele di rosetta e riceve una chiamata
in questa chiamata mi avvisano che avrei
dovuto svolgere uno stage molto
prestigioso presso la missione italiana
dell'onu quindi a new york
avrei dovuto volare fino all'america e
in questi quattro mesi ho realmente
toccato quello che era il mio sogno io
che studio relazioni internazionali mi
trovavo lì a dover lavorare sui diritti
umani
su tutti quei diritti che inglobano ogni
altro diritto che rendono la persona
tale ne sanno una dignità
in quei mesi ho incontrato una varietà
infinita di questa umanità e tutte le
persone che ho incontrato gli hanno
arricchito mi hanno lasciato qualcosa e
soprattutto mi hanno convinto di come
quella esperienza non fosse
un'esperienza qualsiasi perché quell
esperienza per me sono state due ali che
volavano aleggiare come la barriera
celeste dell'onu
oggi quei grattacieli e mi dicevano
esattamente quello che volevo e potevo
diventare oltre tutti i miei limiti
[Applauso]
mentre mentre ero a new york
in quei mesi lavorava ovviamente nel
cuore di manhattan però abitava nel
bronx perché era l'unico posto delle mie
tasti da fuori se potessero permettersi
avevo solo una borsa di studio quindi
dovevo barcamenarmi con tutte le spese
di mattina quando dovevo appunto recarmi
al lavoro
prendevo per 40 minuti lo m
e anche lì dove vos darmela facendo un
sacco di scale e e quindi mentre mi
trovavo in quel crogiolo di culture
origini destinazioni estrazioni sociali
diverse
pensavo che in quella periferia che non
è solo spaziale del mondo
io ero lì si per essere tutto ciò che
potevo essere ma non per essere l'unica
perché in realtà il concetto che
dovrebbe passare è che questo mondo per
essere inclusivo ha bisogno davvero che
io non sia più la prima persona che si
trova a dover fare qualcosa per la prima
volta nonostante la sua disabilità
perché mi piacerebbe essere l'ennesima
una tra le tante tra tante storie di
empowerment personale ecco bisognerebbe
iniziare a pensare che ogni nostra
piccola azione ha un effetto sulle vite
degli altri sta a noi decidere che
questo effetto sia quello di far cadere
ogni tipo di barriera di resistenza gli
ostacoli
basterebbe basterebbe realmente pensare
che non si può considerare se stessi
libri c'è anche solo un altro essere
umano è lasciato indietro
anche anche di un solo singolo giro di
ruota un piccolo passo per l'uomo certo
ma un grande passo verso un umanità più
umana grazie
[Applauso]